that was in this movie you had the tooth
knocked out this time oh yes i
i had a concussion whiplash stitches in
my hand dislocated shoulder yeah there's
been a lot of breaks and sprains and
concussions i think the most
psychologically damaging was when i
broke my penis
a few years ago i was i was trying to
backflip a motorcycle and i can't ride a
motorcycle and i came off the ramp i let
go of the bike it goes 20 feet in the
air
and comes down and breaks its handlebars
off in my crotch
so yeah you know straight to the
hospital
in surgery but that was like over three
years ago and i still have to catheter
twice a day
like a 15 inch tube about the size of a
number two pencil
twice a day wait a second a 15 inch two
lucky wife
i gotta be honest a two-week two would
probably get the job done
so it still hasn't healed not completely
but i have a 10 month old son so it
still works
oh yeah yeah thank you
[Applause]
well listen uh that's i'm saying the
mashed up penis is a very impressive
injury we've got 600 people in our
audience tonight
so uh let's see let's see if we can do
better than that
uh we'll see who's hurt what uh hurt
feelings right there
have you heard anything have you broken
anything no no never
horse riding anything no no no
bungee gone wrong nothing nothing
nothing
absolutely nothing nothing nothing at
all
i can't help you johnny didn't even
bring you oh you broke something
lady up here's broken something
what were you up to i broke my nose i
walked into a tree
i'm sensing drink was involved was it a
great thing
actually it was um my first week in high
school i was on school camp
it was an introduction to our new peers
in new life at high school i was
blindfolded
and it was a trust game
i liked the people you went to school
with that's a really funny game trust me
anyone else had any broken anything oh
you yes having an injury i got a rubber
stuck up
my nose
i heard something else yeah that would
have been a really good injury
the how that happened bit of the story
would have been really good
it was his first time
[Laughter]
did you do it yourself or did someone
else shove it up my brother dared me to
put a pencil up my nose and
you know the yellow ones are the pink
yes
yes yes told me i couldn't take it out
because it would erase my memories
[Applause]
how old were you six oh
but no permanent damage it depends on
what you call
permanent derby
all the injured people very good
excellent
one of the things that attracted you to
aussie was that he doesn't lie
no he does it can't lie and it's like
we'd be at business meetings and i would
you know
lie lie i just embellish things make
them sound better than they actually
are and he'd be why are you saying that
and then i'd be kicking him under the
table
stop kicking me
what's the matter with you and i'm like
oh
but you've lied to him haven't you oh
yes yeah what was the thing about you
rode a motorbike oh
god that was when we were first together
and i wanted to be kind of like hip and
happening and i
i told him that i had a harley davidson
and like i would ride it on a sunday
down to malibu
you know we'll go to that with them dogs
in patagonia would you
oh
we went to patagonia rejected us a
couple of months ago she got i thought
she was going to
wrap around the tree with these dogsled
she wanted to straight carry around as
you're doing all my life
i'll translate
i do know what you're talking about okay
yeah cause no because you were in
adrenaline junkies with jack and you
went to patagonia so you understand me
because uh you you have diversified in
your life into all these different areas
into the kind of film into business and
is that because
realistically it's kind of harder to
make money out of music now yeah it is
but i mean just my personal interest in
the storytelling process
i've been writing songs in it like three
minutes long so you can only
create descriptions the film projects
allow me to develop cause and effect
and you know identify with to be able to
make it visible to the person's defects
you know and where do you stand on this
thing you know because people talk about
how
um all tv you know with uh american idol
and x factor
i've now got a stranglehold on music
that like number one
every week seems to have something i
mean because of the viewership the
viewership is so high i just did the x
factor
i had to go on there with them surely
you've done enough i was like no i'm
gonna perform on it do it
did you get any votes i'm not sure if
they voted but they saw me
[Applause]
did you meet the ex factorines yeah all
right so
did you see the perform i did i did was
it marco
irvana and and another another girl
[Music]
oh no there's a next factor in italy
someone just stole me in my ear yeah
that's why they called marco and
giovanni and things
did you see how politely though we
handled that because we thought you
would have lost your mind
[Applause]
[Laughter]
arrived in europe i'm in europe
do you own parrots yes no i i i do yes
how many how many do you have i've got
two
uh two parrots um and uh a
moloken cockatoo and a triton cockatoo
there and then you like a cockatoo
don't you yes
i'm sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
we were walking down the corridor and
there was a door marked innuendo
shall i open it no i shout
i was there
you're just dodging the eyes
yeah rescue birds that we got from a
rescue center we don't we only take on
birds uh that
for whom they've already had several
owners do you exercise your birth
yes we do we well in the wild
parrots um particularly cockatoos will
forage
on the forest floor rather than to fly
about and so they
love to run and forage in the in the
ground so we would take them to richmond
park and put them on harnesses
and just walk them around
but the dogs don't want to kill your
parrots
the size of their beaks right these dogs
there's some sort of evolutionary
sort of light bulb going off somewhere
yeah
maybe not you know i've seen the footage
of stephen and
that bird's gonna get on my head and try
and get the wax out my ear and get off
his face
like you've got some top tips in the gym
well i got inspired you know
like i think most people you go in waves
where like this is gonna be the time
where i'm gonna get in that crazy shape
and and i and i and i went to the gym
and i was working out and
and i i had chosen a day when all of a
sudden randomly arnold schwarzenegger
walked into the gym that i was in
yeah and he was like you know this is
when he was the governor i knew i was in
the right gym right
i tried to put some more weights on so i
would look more impressive
i think he knew the gym owner or
something and he was taking a tour or
something and
he approached me and and i i don't know
if he knew me as an actor or just he was
like
you know he's the governor like hello
citizen
he said what are your goals with your
workout
i was i was so on your spot but i i
retreated to this just
very little boy place and i was like
well to be honest um
arnold um i if i could have anything i'd
really like to have
um did you ever see the movie fight club
um i
like the way brad pitt's abs looked in
fight club
and uh he said without hesitating he
said that's that's all diet you have to
eat a lot of carrots
and i didn't know i was like okay of
course in my mind i'm like arnold
schwarzenegger he was like miss universe
so i
i missed your universe not me
what a career
a lot of people don't know that he was
also misuniversal
too many steroids but i then he uh he so
i ran home and i bought
a ton of carrots and i was eating
them for weeks but nothing nothing ever
happened no
very nice to see you all and that we're
excited to see all three of you
but i happen to know that cameron you
are very excited to see sir david
i am so excited yes
[Applause]
we were making a sir david attenborough
sandwich by
he's the meat in the middle of our
sandwich right now
leave you to it wear his slices of bread
she's a nice french stick and i'm an
almost also
that was what i thought that i was going
to be my entire life i wanted to study
the um
[Applause]
but i ended up studying the behavior of
animals it just happened to be human
animals
really yes you know as an actor that's
what i do i study
human behavior lots of discovery yes
lots of big surprises
i find so many more surprises when i
watch your show yes
should see the outtakes
maybe we can arrange a view yes
you